vor wir gleich diskutieren schauen uns
vielleicht gemeinsam ein paar Bilder an
um mal klar zumachen worüber wir hier
reden und es beginnt direkt mit einem
Ausschnitt in dem sie herer zu sehen
sind bittte
schön sch Nummer
ein od ganz hinten der Schaf Nummer 5
das ist der zweite wolfsangriff jetzt
hier wie soll das weitergehen das ist ja
deichutz verdt noch mal wo sind wir hier
D soll die Leute eben absaufen hinter
Deich dann können wir nicht mehr
schützen ist es eben so fertig
aus dieses Video vonr aus Niedersachsen
ging im frühahr in den sozialen Medien
viral der ehemalige hobbychäfer ist
einer von vielen die genug haben vom
Wolf Wölfe tauchen immer wieder in
Ortschaften auf in der Nähe von
Kindergärten kommen nachts auf die
Weiden reißen teilweise dutzende
vontieren auf einmal die Betroffenen
fordern von der Politik endlich den
Abschuss zu
erlauben seit mehr als 20 Jahren ist der
Wolf zurück in Deutschland vor allem im
Nordosten nachdem er fast 150 Jahre lang
als aus gerottet galt inzwischen sind
über 1300 sesshafte Wölfe nachgewiesen
und die Population verdoppelt sich alle
Jahre Tierschützer dagegen fordern statt
Abschuss besseren Herdenschutz mit
Elektrozäunen und Hunden doch die
Wirksamkeit ist
umstritten die Bundesumweltministerin
Steffi Lemke will jetzt den Abschuss
sogenannter problemwölfe erleichtern hat
aber damit nur eine neue Diskussion
losgetreten während die Lockerungen
vielen Betroffenen nicht weit genug
gehen waren Naturschützer davor dass
dieser Schuss buchstäblich nach hinten
losgeht denn geschwäch der Rudel würden
erst recht auf Nutztiere gehen sagen
Experten Frage bleibt also was ist zu
tun wie kann ein Zusammenleben von
Mensch und Wolf
Aussehen ja schön guten Abend ihnen
beiden find schon sehr gut klar geworden
sie sagten das vor der Sendung her Meer
vielleicht beginne ich unhöflicherweise
direkt mit ih ihn man muss sich sehr
genau überlegen ob man sich zu diesem
Thema ins Fernsehen setzt warum ja der
Wolf polarisiert sehr ich kann das auch
nachvollziehen ich bin auch durchaus
Wolfs Freund das kann ich so sagen ich
bin Hundefreund Hundefreund ist ist auch
wolfsfreund das ist das Urtier unserem
Lieblingstieren die wir alle bei uns im
Haus halten die Hunde und das zeigt uns
eigentlich wo die herkommen und darum
ist der Wolf natürlich was ganz
Besonderes das ist keine Frage und mich
als als landwt aber als Jäger fasziniert
das Tier genauso wie andere auch aber
haben wir eine Polarisierung die weit
über das normale Maß hinausgeht und es
scheint so dass ich nur ganz gewisse
Leute anscheinend äußern sollen zum
Thema Wolf aber die Betroffenen die
müssen wie ich meine viel mehr zu Wort
kommen auch nicht nur soll sondern auch
wollen ne also es ist nicht leicht wenn
man aus aus redaktioneller Sicht wenn
man Leute sucht Gäste sucht die zu dem
Thema in einer Sendung diskutieren und
no lange suchen sie können sich nicht
vorstellen wie oft ich gewarnt wurde
jetzt vor der Sendung es kam ja raus
jetzt geht zu Herr Lanz und dann kam oh
weißt du das hast du das gut besprochen
das ist schlimm das geht aber nicht und
wir K können un sich verstecken wir
haben ein Problem das müssen wir
besprechen da mssen wir den besten Weg
finden und das geht n wenn man auch die
Erfahrung die man macht auch von sich
gibt und nicht wenn man sie sich dann
unterschlucken lässt und darum bin ich
gerne hier und freue mich das ja freue
mich auch ging ihn auch so Frau
salberart also dass sie gewarnt werden
sozusagen das öffentlich zu diskutieren
nein nein hat mich keiner gewarnt und
auch wenn mich jemand gewarnt hätte wäre
ich trotzdem
gekommen warum ist diese Diskussion so
aufgeheizt was würden Sie sagen
ich bin ja selber ähm scharfhalterin
gewesen über 30 Jahre und ich kann sie
sehr gut verstehen Herr loheier weil ich
hatte auch selbst die Erfahrung gemacht
dass mir ein Husky drei Lämmer gerissen
hat und ich kam auf die Weide und habe
meine Toten Lämmer die ich ja halt
selbst auch was weiß ich bei der Geburt
geholfen habe habe ich auf der Weide
liegen sehen das hat mich auch sehr
geschockt deshalb kann ich ihre Position
auch sehr gut
nachvollziehen ähm aber ich denke es
hängt natürlich auch mit der Geschichte
des Wolfes zusammen bis vor 150 Jahren
war ja oder ach nein vor 150 Jahren war
Europa ja praktisch wolfsfrei genauso
wie USA ja der Wolf ist halt irgendwie
sicherlich auch durch die bestimmte
Mythen sozusagen in die Rolle des Bösen
und des Teufels
gekommen
geradechenchen der
Klassiker
dadurch ein Thema was natürlich sehr
polarisiert wo auch sehr viel mit Angst
gearbeitet wird sicherlich auch über die
Medien weil es steht sie lesen halt
immer Wolf hat im Blutrausch was weiß
ich Schafe getötet und es wird eben auch
sehr etwas unsachlich beschrieben aber
no mal kurz Nachfrage sie sind t das
machen die doch auch ne also wenn wenn
wenn so Wolf erstmal wirklich dabei ist
dann werden ja das so verstehe ich das
auch ich erlebe das häufiger mal in in
Südtirol beispielsweise auch bei bei bei
Nachbarn und so weiter das ist das was
die mehmer erzählen die sagen wenn der
kommt und wenn der ein Schaf reißt dann
bleibt's nicht bei einem Schaf dann
werden noch viele viele weitere Tiere
häufig getötet einfach liegen gelassen
liegen dann halbsterbenend darum und das
ist das was die die Wut der Leute so
triggert gut das ist ein typisches
Verhalten von kaninen und marerartigen
und zwar das ist eine verhaltenskette
dazu können diese Tiere nicht ne das ich
bitte ich hab nicht den W ich will ganz
gerne kurz beschreiben wenn Sie möchten
ja und zwar das ist so es gibt diese
verhaltneskette das ist zuerst dass die
Tiere sich orientieren dann fixieren
dann hetzen jagen packen töten das ist
die verhaltenskette die einen Wolf oder
Fuchs macht ja bei Hunden ist das
rausgezüchtet da geht es je nachdem
wofür der Hund eingesetzt wird bis zum
Jagen oder auch bis zum Packen bei
manchen Hunden bei Herdenschutzhunden
ist die verhaltenskette nur sich
orientieren fixieren und gut ist ja das
ist sozusagen rausgezüchtet und aber bei
unseren kaniden ist das sozusagen
genetisch festgelegt die können nicht
anders und daher kommt dieser Ausdruck
Blutrausch wenn die Tiere jetzt nicht in
der Herde wären sondern verstreut dann
würden sich ein scharf greifen und die
anderen die werden im Wald die werden
weg aber dadurch dass dass es dass das
immer wieder ausgelöst wird versteh
dieses davon laufende Tiere fängt diese
verhtenskette immer wieder von vorne an
und es ergibt den Blutrausch ich
verstehe es ist sehr interessant sie
sagen auch gleichzeitig um das noch mal
ganz kurz zu klären Menschen greifen in
der Regel Wölfe nicht an Wölfe greifen
Menschen in der Regel nicht an nein tun
sie nicht nein Wölfe haben Angst vor
Menschen sagen sie
das heißt gibt es überlieferte Fälle wo
Wölfe Menschen angegriffen haben es gibt
Fälle von Tollwut wo Wölfe Tollwut
hatten ja okay das machen Füchse auch
und Hunde auch das was anderes und es
gibt die
die Beschreibung dass Wölfe sich zu nahe
in die den Menschen gegenüber also sehr
in die Nähe von Menschen begeben haben
wenn sie angefüttert wurden ja das war
ja das Beispiel bei Kurti Kurti hat
glaube ich irgendwo in der lüdeburger
Heide gewohnt und hat sich wirklich zu
sehr den Menschen genährt der wurde auch
in nommen ein junger Wolf ja ja ich
glaube der war zwei oder drei
ursprünglich mal ja genau ja es war ist
auch okay also da sehen wir hier Bilder
aus lohen ne Niedersachsen wo so ein
Wolf am hellichten Tag hat ein Vater mit
seinem Sohn aufgenommen da sehen wir
auch gerade den den das Kind ne den den
kleinen hab wir da gerade kurz am
zebarstreifen gesehen der Wolf läuft
einfach vorbei und dann sehr schön biegt
dann links ab zu Lidl zu Lidl ja ist ist
das gefährlich nein B mal hier jetzt
also sieht auch nicht gefährlich aus
aber sie verstehen aber dass Leute Angst
kriegen wenn sie so eine Begegnung hab
es könnte ja auch ein Hund sein also
Wolf ist das tröstet mich nicht es gibt
mehr Übergriffe durch durch Hunde als
durch Wölfe mhm okay also auf auf auf
Menschen gibt dann anderes Beispiel
vielleicht können die Kollegen aus der
Regie das auch einmal kurz zuspielen
eine Joggerin in dem Fall ich glaube in
Niedersachsen vielleicht können wir das
einmal kurz zeigen
wo die Frau glaube ich instinktiv
richtig gehandelt hat und sehr laut
wurde wir hören mal kurz rein
genau geh weg
mm
ich meine ja perfekt die macht genau
richtig perfekt aber ich ich verstehe
auch ehrlich sie macht super aber die
die Angst der Frau verstehe ich an dem
Punkt wenn du da alleine so über die
Wiese Jobst und plözlich stehst du
wirklich vor einem
Wolf da wird mir ein bisschen die
Gänsehaut über den Rücken runterlaufen
das sind oft Jungwölfe die noch keine
Erfahrung haben und die sind einfach
neugierig und ja etwas risikofreudig sie
kennen sich natürlich damit aus aber
wenn man damit nicht so betraut oder
vertraut der stellt sich ja nicht vor
und sagt guten Tag ich bin ein Jungwolf
und ich will nur
spielen her ler in Ihrem Fall ist das
ein bisschen anders sie sagen das ist
eine Gefahr das ist eine Gefahr vor
alleningen für die Tiere ich habe vorhin
gesagt Sie haben aufgehört Schafe zu
züchten nicht weil ihre eigenen Schafe
gerissen worden wären sondern es
betrifft die Schafe der Nachbarn die wir
diesem Video gesehen
haben wie ist die Situation wie hat das
Problem sozusagen zugenommen genau
zunchst die nar die wir jetzt schon
wieder gehört haben ich finde sie
faszinierend wir haben diese Art der
Begegnung wir sie gerade gesehen haben
fast täglich und es hie früer wir werden
nie ein Wolf zu Gesicht bekommen ein
Sechser im Lotto gleich ich kenne also
Millionen von ganz viele Leute die haben
die Millionen gewonnen aber noch nicht
ausgezahlt also wir sehen alle Wölf und
zwar sie selber selbstverständlich auch
in unseren Dörfern wenn wir im Wald sind
im Wald ist es in Ordnung aber in den
Dörfern ist es nicht in Ordnung wir
haben in unseren der Wolf der das bei
mir ausgelöst hat was ich gleich
beschreibe wird regelmäßig am helligen
Tag fotografiert diese Frau hat einen
Schock fürs Leben bekommen andere Frauen
und auch in Burgdorfer Holz gab es eine
ganz dramatische Begegnung die war nur
die Frau hat gesagt wenn kein Schnee
gelegen hätte hätte ich mich gar nicht
getraut das zu sagen hätte mir keiner
geglaubt durch das Schnee konnte man das
aber nachvollziehen man konnte das
Ministerium hinfahren auch der
ministeriumsmitarbeiter hat mir das
bestätigt ich hätte es nicht geglaubt
aber es war so es ist wirklich
dramatisch die Wölfe laufen die Leute an
sie verfolgen sie mit dem Fahrrad das
ist beschrieben sie verfolgen sie mit
dem Pferd also hinter den Pferden
hinterher das ist beschrieben und man
kann n froh sein dass das gut geht und
ich bin froh dass nicht meine Kinder da
gestanden haben einfach nur spazieren
gegangen sind in der in den Feldern wie
wir das gemacht haben das macht diese
Frau nicht mehr ihre Kinder noch mal
rauszulassen das muss man ganz klar
sagen das verändert das Leben auf dem
Land massiv und jetzt in der dunklen
Jahreszeit stehen unsere Kinder um 7 Uhr
im Dunkeln an die busheit Stellen und
wenn Sie ein Landwirt sagte zu mir wir
haben jetzt acht Rinder verloren wir
stehen vor diesen großen Rindern die
teilweise mehrere hundert Kilo wiegen
wir wissen was die Wölfe machen wir
sehen Sie im Scheinwerferlicht über die
Straße laufen und ich soll meine Kinder
morgens wie wir es immer gemacht haben
um 7 uh Z Bushaltestelle ohne Lampe das
geht nicht mehr und die Frau sagte mir
ich komme von der Arbeit um 18 Uhr
Bustür geht auf ich steige aus Bus geht
zu fährt weg und dann stehe ich da so
und das ist nicht übertrieben wenn man
diese Bilder die jetzt hier gezeigt W
zum Teil mit Rind und Pferden gesehen
hat da kannst du keine Menschen übel
nehmen dass Gefühl hat darf ich nur noch
einmal dazwischen Fragen hat in ihrer
Gegend jemals ein Wolf ein Kind in
irgendeiner Form angefallen ist gekommen
ist wir haben noch kein Angriff auf
Kinder wir haben jetzt einen Angriff in
Holland gehabt da hat ein Schäfer
versucht den Wolf aus dem der hat die
Schafe gerissen wollte aus der Weide
raustreiben und da kommen wir zu dem
Problem das hat nicht geklappt der Wolf
hat dann den Schäfer in die Hand
gebissen und wurde nachher von der
Polizei in der Weide noch erschossen da
haben wir das Problem diese Weidezäune
haben viele Probleme aber ein Problem
ist die Tiere kommen halt nicht weg die
Weidetiere das heißt die Schafe reißen
und die Weidetiere können ja gar nicht
mehr flüchten und je besser diese Zäune
sind je stabiler die sind desto weniger
gibtup eine Chance dass die vielleicht
über ein Netz Rü springen und einfach
der den Wolf entfliehen und somit kommen
Sie den Wolf immer wieder nah der Wolf
ist nicht böse das ist nicht böse das
ist die Natur ein Reh ist auch nicht
böse weil genau ein RE ist auch nicht
böse weil es den Wald auffrisst das ist
seine Natur das ist eben Natur und da
wird dieser Reflex ausgelöst aber mit
diesem ver verhenden ja diesen
verherenden Auswirkungen und das habe
ich ja nun mal beim Nachbar nemen
gesehen da liegen die Toten Schafe
angefressen war ein einziges tatsächlich
am Ende aber die sieben oder acht lagen
da tot das war dann am 15 kurz vorher
war schon sein Übergriff und das heißt
eines war sozusagen hungerstillen und
der Rest war das was sie gerade
beschrieben haben die flüchten eben ins
Wasser und ich war auch deswegen so
aufgelöst wenn ich jetzt das im
Nachhinein betrachte weil ich mir
eingestehen muss dass ich eigentlich in
dem Moment gemerkt habe jetzt ist
Feierabend für deine Schafe diese Bilder
habe ich gesehen ich war ein Kilometer
entfernt habe immer gesagt wenn soweit
ist dass der Wolf über die Weser zu
unserer Seite kommt und bei mir in den
in der SCH Pferde ist dann ist es nicht
so dass der eben ein Schaf reißt das
auffrisst abhaut und dann kommt der
Start und zaht man noch sogar das Schaf
als Ersatz da wäre alles gut da muss ein
scharfhalter mit leben dass man Tier
getötet wird das ist normal das gehört
mit dazu nein die Tiere flüchten ins
Wasser massenweise und dann kann werde
ich vielleicht angerufen ich komme dahin
die Tiere liegen im Wasser ertrinken
elendig liegen mit offenem Bäuchen auf
dem Deichen das sind fürchterliche
Bilder die kaum zu ertragen sind und das
schlimme ist wenn das alles dann
abgearbeitet wurde am nächsten Tag du
setzt dich abends dann
erschöpft auf dein Sofa und weiß eins
heute Nacht kann er wiederkmen und das
ist ein Gedanke da kann kein Tierhalter
weitermachen das geht nicht mehr wir
sind in einem Zustand der das Tier was
wir gerade sehen das lebt noch nicht und
das ist bitter das sowas kenne ich
höchstens von von Verkehrsunfällen wo du
als Jäger hingerufen wirst da kennen wir
solche Bilder da können wir das hier
lösen ich habe aber damals auch gesagt
als ich wolfsberater war ich komme nicht
zu einem Verkehrsunfall solange ich den
Wolf dann nicht auch erlösen darf wenn
der noch schwerst krank dort liegt die
Regeln sind so verrückt da musste erst
sein amtswiederin her kommen und
feststellen dass der Wolf nicht den Art
Erhalt mir dient bevor dies arme Tier
erlöst werden konnte also auch die Wölfe
trifft es mit dieser unsäcklichen Tier
mus einm verstehen also wenn der Wolf
wird jetzt beispielsweise von einem Auto
angefahren oder so wird verletzt schwer
verletzt auf der straßeau und sie als
Jäger könnten einmal den erlösenden
Schuss auslösen wild W das Leid beendet
das dürfen sie aber beim Wolf nicht da
kann die Polizei dan nehmen steh darf es
auch nicht da musste da musste bis jetzt
das hat sich jetzt Gott sei Dank
geändert ein amtswiterin kommen musste
wo kriegt man die Nacht her musste dann
erst sagen vor Ort nein der kann dem Art
Erhalt nicht mehr dienen und durfte den
dann einschläfern so war die Regelung
okay das ist aber jetzt vorbei ja das
ist jetzt entschärft aber damals war
eine ganze Autobahn gesperrt war genau
die Szenerie war und es war kein
amtswiedterin her zu finden das habe ich
ihn auch geschickt das ist das sind
Sachen die gehen nicht und die sind
einfach drüber das ist für mich
Tierquälerei staatlich verordnet das
muss man runterfahren so etwas und das
sehen wir bei den Schafen genauso für
mich ist das auch staatlich verordnete
Tierquälerei die Bilder hatten wir vor
2015 überhaupt nicht und jetzt haben wir
sie täglich das können wir nichtagen
vielleicht vielleicht schauen wir weil
gerade sagten sie waren so aufgelöst
vielleicht schauen wir einmal kurz rein
schauen uns diesen diesen Moment noch
mal an der bei ihnen offensichtlich viel
ins Rollen gebracht hat bitttechön so da
ist die Herde mit einigen
verletzten Schaf Nummer
1 oder ganz hinten der Schaf Nummer 5
tot hinten klarer kehlbiss nichts
gefressen nur
getötet das ist ein Deich hier und ich
kann diesen Deich nicht absperren der
ist viele viele Kilometer lang das
funktioniert
nicht das der zweite wolfsangriff jetzt
hier wie soll das weitergehen wie soll
das funktionieren was ma ich jetzt
meinen Schafen das ist ja Deichschutz
verdamt noch mal wo sind wir hier D
sollen die Leute eben absaufen hinterm
Deich dann können wir ihm nicht mehr
schützen dann ist es eben so fertig aus
dann machen wirer Kulturlandschaft wi
Naturreservat hier himmelarsch und
zwiren dieser scheißptik diese
Verlogenheit in der Politik diese
Vollidioten unglaublich alles machen sie
kaputt sehr sauer Herr Loher was was was
fordern Sie was verlangen Sie dass
endlich die Realität anerkannt wird wir
hören die ganze Zeit was von da man kann
die Tiere doch so einfach schützen also
normal sagt mir dann immer jemand die
fünf Worte man muss einfach doch nur und
das war dann man muss doch einfach nur
ist ganz einfach und es ist in der
Praxis e überhaupt nicht einfach in der
Praxis sehen wir es schaltert man kann
natürlich sagen alle weiter die Halter
sind Kollektiv zu dämlich sie sind nicht
in der Lage die Zeit aufzubringen das
Geld aufzubringen und diese diese
Leistung zu erbringen einer
weitertierhaltung verdient kaum einer
wirklich Geld seine Familie ernähren
mindest kann man damit nicht erziehen
wir sind jetzt nicht damit in einem
Bereich wo wir riesen Millionen Euro da
verdienen sondern es ist eine Leistung
wie Deichschutz um Naturschutz
Artenschutz und das alles
un können Sie das einmal mal kurz
erklären Ihre spezielle Situation also
Deich für Deiche damit Deiche gut sind
intakt sind ist es wichtig dass da
Schafe drauf weilen Schafe haben Clau in
der Mitte gespalten sind sage ich mal
und wenn ein lauseloch da ist treten die
halb rein treten wenn das Waser steigt
kann nicht mehr in den Deich so leicht
reinlaufen Schafe sind perfekt um jetzt
gerade im Spätherbst eine gute
grassnarbe zu machen und fressen das Gut
kurz so dass wir ein super Deich haben
das können Sie mit Maschinen an der an
Steinen Bereichen kaum nach gar nicht
möglich kostenloser deichchutz Kost
deichchutz und wenn man so kostenlos
wenn man so will aber er ist wichtig 70%
der Menschen wohnen Niedersachsen fast
hinterm Deich viele wissen es gar nicht
auch hier die flussdeiche die wir gerade
sehen das ist einfach wichtig und das
hat über Jahrzehnte Jahrhunderte fast
funktioniert und jetzt erleben wir das
eine Art ein der Wolf wieder zurückkommt
das ist erstmal erfreulich natürlich
aber es wird so naiv von der Politik
begleitet da fällt ein Nichts zu ein B
einmal konkret herer Frau Salbert sagt
Zäune das ist auch das Argument dass ich
häufig höre dann macht ordentliche Zäune
dann kommt ein Wolfs nicht rein sie
sagen das geht möglicherweise irgendwo
in Bayern oder in den Alpen oder an
bestimmten Ecken aber bei mir auf dem
Deich geht das nicht warum nicht also
ich darf an der Weser das ist eine
Bundeswasserstraße wie eine
Bundesautobahn nur für Schiffe darf ich
ent lang der Wasserlinie keinen Zaun
ziehen durfte ich noch nie und das wurde
auch dann noch mal bestätigt nein das
ist auch jetzt nicht erlaubt weil diese
Zäune in die ins Wasser geraten können
da fen Schiffe wenn die sich da rein
verwickeln haben wir eine Katastrophe
aber auch das natürlich Tier also die
Wasser das sind Staustufen die werden
hoch gefahren manchmal die Weser oder es
regnet irgendwo in in der röhen und auf
einmal sind die zollen odter Wasser aber
auch es gibt andere Rechte wie
angelrechte die dürfen an das Wasser
wenn hier ein Tier rüber schwimmt über
die Weser landet es an einem Elektrozaun
all solche Probleme gibt es da also so
einfach ist das nicht und wir haben
viele andere Sachen wir haben gerade ein
Urteil bekommen dass die
Herdenschutzhunde eben nachts
weggesperrt werden müssen weil sie wegen
Lärmschutz das geht so nicht mehr da
kommen wir einfach an Grenzen der
Naturland der Kulturlandschaft das ist
meine Überzeugung und der Wolf kommt
jetzt hier in diese Kulturlandschaft
rein wir sind ein sehr dicht besiedeltes
Flächenland 250 Einwohner pro
Quadratkilometer Finnland und Schweden
haben 25 Einwohner und in Europa im
Schnitt 100 so und in diesem Flächenland
kann der Wolf gar nicht am Menschen
vorbei er wird sich immer annähren der
Wolf kann nichts dafür der Mensch ist
ein täglich für ihn vorhandenes Element
der der der Landschaft er kann dem kaum
ausweichen das heißt der Wolf kann da
gar nichts für dass er sich den Menschen
annähert wenn er sich verbreitet und wir
haben in Deutschland mittlerweile die
höchste wolfsdichte fast der Welt und
das bei einer so hohen Einwohnerzahl
dass sich das beißt ist doch ganz klar
und das erste Mal in der Geschichte
lassen wir den Wolf an uns ran ohne ihn
abzuwehren wir haben ihn immer auf
Distanz gehalten in allen Ländern wo er
ist wird er auf Distanz gehalten er hat
einen Grund sich fernzuhalten und hier
trifft auf eine weidetierhaltung die
jetzt versucht mit unfassbaren Einsatz
von Kapital von Geld der Staat gibt
wahnsinnig viel dafür aus Zäune zu
ziehen die aber offenkundig nicht wirken
wir haben in den risstabellen des
Umweltministeriums Niedersachsens fast
jeden Tag einen Riss hinter einem
solchen Grundschutz und ganz wichtig das
Geld ist alle die haben schon mehrere
Millionen Euro hat der Nr berichtet über
das hinaus genehmigt an zuen als
eigentlich da sind und wir fangen ja
jetzt erst im Bereich an wo Rinder und
Pferde immer mehr angegriffen werden und
wie soll das weitergehen für mich ist da
keine Option mehr weiter Weid okay sie
sind zwei sehr dankbare Gäste weil ich
muss gar nicht viel tun sie sie erzählen
einfach was das Thema ist es ist sehr
interessant ich muss aber ein bisschen
sortieren ähm äh weideehunde ist eben
oder Schutzhunde ist eben als STI
herchutzunde genau die einen bestimmten
namen haben helfen Sie mirenschutzunde
Kang Kang genau so die ist gerade als
Stichwort gefallen äh Herr lum sagte
gerade da gab's dieses Urteil nachts ich
meine nachts kommen die Wölfe bitte aber
drin halten weil machen so viel Krach
was ist das für ein spezielles Urteil
kennen sie das ja das ist für Fall und
da ging's darum dass in einem sehr
kleinen Ort eine Frau sieben
Herdenschutzhunde hat die sie aber bei
einer Tierzahl die eine so große Anzahl
von Herdenschutzhunden gar nicht
erfordert und diese Hunde haben
praktisch wirklich die ganze Nacht
gebellt der hatte so viele von den ja
und ja die hat und die hat aber auch
Stelle wo sie die Tiere unterbringen
kann und die hat auch Elektrozaun und da
ist dieses individuelle Urteil okay
gangen dass die ihre Hunde nachts drin
haben muss was ich definitiv in dem Fall
auch verstehe ist interessant okay das
klingt total bescheuert hat macht aber
in dem individuellen Sinn dem
individuellen Teil macht Sinn und Herr
Lom ja ich möchte sie noch ein bisschen
korrigieren es sind 75% der
wolfsübergrisse Griffe sind auf
Herden die nicht
die kein funktionieren den Grundschutz
hatten also es wo wo in Deutschland 75%
also das Tiere die nicht äquat geschützt
die nichtquat gesch wie kann wie kann
man das machen sie sagen ich ich habe
das in einem Interview von Ihnen gelesen
Frau Salbert sie sagen man kann das
machen aber es ist das sagen auch sie
verdammt viel Arbeit es ist aufwendig
wie kann man Tiere wie kann man Schafe
Rinde auch ich ich kenne auch die
Geschichten gerade selber war ich gerade
Zeuge auch zweimal sogar einmal 400 kg
Kalb und einmal 800 kg
Rind von von
Wölfen zugerichtet und natürlich dabei
gestorben auf einer Alm mhm im Grunde
nicht zu schützen sie können nicht eine
gesamte Alm mit einem mit einem starken
Elektrozaun
einzunen also in allen Gebieten weiß ich
in der Schweiz dass die auch mit
herdenschutzunden Arbeiten okay aber es
kommt auf die Almen an es gibt natürlich
Gegenden die sehr verwinkelt und
verzwickt sind wo praktisch Herdenschutz
in dem Sinn nicht möglich ist und
genauso wie sie sagen dass es in
bestimmten deichgebieten sehr sehr
schwierig ist die Herde zu schützen ich
weiß auch in in der Gegend von
Schermbeck da ist auch Waldgebiet wo
praktisch die Wacholderheide beweidet
wurde wo die Schäfer dieses Waldstück
auch nicht mehr beweiden können weil es
nicht zu schützen ist es das muss man
akzeptieren es ist einfach so ja sagen
es gibt es gibt
stell
geht aber es gibt die bei den meisten
Flächen geht es und zwar die brauchen
wichtig ist
ein funktionierender Elektrozaun ein
untergrabeschutz ja dass die die Wölfe Z
Teil drunter durch die meisten Wölfe
buddeln erstmal und versuchen unten
durchzukommen K und jetzt ist ja auch
praktisch eine eine Herde mit 5 da sind
sickerhirsche von Wölfen getötet worden
da war aber ein nicht funktionierender
untergrabeschutz ja es gibt die
Möglichkeit oben drüber noch eine
elektrolitze zu machen und den den
Schutz unten den auch noch mal
Elektrozaun Strom ist das der allerbeste
Tierschutz finde ich wenn die Wölfe
konditioniert sind dass die beim Anblick
eines Schafes wenn die jetzt vom Osten
kommen sofort einen verplätet kriegen
und sofort einen ordentlichen strschlag
die müssen richtigen ordentlichen
Stromschlag kriegen und wenn die Tiere
geschützt sind wenn die ordnungsgemäß
geschützt sind dann passiert das zwei
dreimal dann lernen die Wölfe Schafe tun
weh also gehe ich nicht mehr an Schafe
sondern halt und ich finde auch dass die
Wölfe wie sie auch gesagt haben die
sollen auch aus den Ortschaften draußen
bleiben die sollen im Wald bleiben und
das können machen sie dann wenn sie
sehen Schafe sind keine Beute und Rinder
auch nicht und Pferde auch nicht und das
kriegen sie nur wenn sie so
konditioniert sind das das es wirklich
mit einem richtigen Stromschlag
verbunden ist einmal für mich nur nur
technisch wie wie hoch muss so ein Zaun
sein also meiner Ansicht nach also
Mindestmaß ist 90 cm das finde ich ein
bisschen zu wenig obwohl ich sagen muss
diese 12 m hohen elektrozule zu
schleppen das ist eine halenarbeit das
geht fast nicht also das ist so ein
bisschen der der Kraftaufwand der dabei
eingesetzt werden muss und und der
Nutzen das ist das ist halt auch schon
eine Differenz das ist so und wie viel
wie hoch sind die Zäune die ihre
Nachbarn ihre Freunde benutzen also wir
haben auch für perd für die
pferdeschutzzeune 140 hoch 14 sogar aber
ich muss einfach sagen aber sie haben
Litzen oder Litzen natürlich len ist
litzenzaun and also das richtig also
stoffzaun kaum zubauen weil in der
Realität auch einfach vom Wind schon
umgewäht wird das hält einfach windlass
gar nicht mehr aus und das also das hält
einfach nicht mehr und dann muss da
richtig Strom rein da muss richtig Strom
sein also was Frau Seibert beschreibt
das ist in der Theorie alles ganz
fantastisch aber das dove ist dass wir
in der Lebenswirklichkeit Leben und
agieren und das Thema Schafe ist ehrlich
gesagt schon bald gar nicht mehr das
Thema weil die gibt's eigentlich bald
gar nicht mehr wenn immer weniger Herden
in den meisten im landkis nburg bei uns
W es immer weniger das heißt die Rinder
gehen die Rinder sind jetzt dran und die
Rinder sind in riesengruppen die kann
ich nicht einzäuen das zahlt mir auch
kein Mensch und wir haben die ganzen
Bilder jetzt dass sie in Gang gesetzt
werden und in Gang gesetzt werden des
Nachts das überwachen wir unserer Firma
ja auch mittlerweile nachts weil wir
nachts die Herden uns anschauen und da
ist eine riesengfahr die zur Zeit auf
uns zukommt wenn die nämlich ausbrechen
auf die schienengelagen auf die Straßen
in diesem eng besiedelten Licht Land da
haben wir ein riesen Problemem was auf
uns zukommt denn das nimmt zu von den
letzten 20
rissen die in der risstabelle des Landes
Niedersachsen waren waren 15 Rind oder
Pferd und nur fünf scharf also Schaf ist
schon fast out für die Rinder für die
wöfe und die lernen es gerade
weiterzugeben an die Rinder ran und ich
kann ihn da sagen das ist in der Praxis
kommum noch umzusetzen wenn einmal
solche Rinder ausgebückst sind oder
Pferde ausgebückst sind bis sie die
wieder drin haben das lernt ein
Tierhalter das Risiko geht er nie wieder
ein weil die Fallhöhe das da ein
schlimmer Unfall passiert sie wissen
vielleicht ICE in fulder ist entgleist
2008 durch eine scharfferde in einen
Tunnel reingebretterten 170 Menschen und
ich möchte kein zweites ter haben und
die Politik sollte sich gut überlegen ob
sie diese Bilder diese Tendenz dass die
Wölfe gerade die Rinderherden angehen so
massiv wie wir das ja sehen ob sie das
wirklich schweigend so hinnehmen möchte
und noch etwas in dieser Tabelle wird
ganz klar festgestellt ob ein
Grundschutz vorhanden war ordnungsgemäß
jeden Tag sterben in Niedersachsen
mindestens ein Tier teilweise deutlich
mehr in einer Herde die mit einem
Grundschutz festgestellt gesichert war
es funktioniert so einfach nicht es ist
nur eine Challenge für die Wölfe sie
müssen sehen dass wie sie damit klarkmen
die finden andere Wege da reinzukommen
ob sie buddeln wir haben sogar Rinder
die gerissen wurden obwohl die Rinder
und Pferde angeblich gar nicht in
beutelchema gehören hieß es ja am Anfang
woso wurde mir als wolberater
beigebracht hat n mit der
lebenswglichkeit ne nicht kann und da
war sogar ein Grundschutz der war sogar
aufricht das heißt der Wolf ist unter
dem Grundschutz durch hat dann noch ein
Kalb gerissen also hat zwei Sachen
gleich gemacht h nicht darf und es
passiert nichts und da fragt man sich
was sollte noch alles gemacht werden es
ist nicht so dass die Tierhalter sich
dem verweigern wir haben unfassbar viel
Geld ausgegeben ich habe weit über 20
000 € ausgegeben aus eigener Tasche um
meine Tiere zu schützen weil man bekommt
den Zaun bezahlt das Aufbauen das
Pflegen was ein Dauerauftrag ist das ist
auf jeden Tag aufs Neue muss ich gucken
ob alles in Ordnung ist muss jeden
Fehler machen und wenn Sie ein
gerissenes Tier haben dann kommt jemand
schaut sich das Tier an und sagt jetzt
gucken wir erstmal ob der ganze Zaun in
Ordnung ist woll mal messen oha da ist
aber ein Baum Ast draufgefallen hier ist
aber dies hier ist aber jenes und am
Ende heißt es noch du hast deine Tiere
gar nicht geschützt weil der Zaun war
nicht ordnungsgemäß das ist als wenn sie
ein Reh Anfahren rufen die Polizei und
der sagt Moment Stopp Reifen abgefahren
Bremse nicht gut ich würde mal sagen
wenn die Reifen gut gewesen wenden Sie
das reger nicht er angefahren jetzt
kriegen sie anzig tierquehlerei man
kriegt eine Überprüfung und man fühlt
sich als Tierhalter als wenn du von
Opfer zum Täter gemacht wirst obwohl man
war nicht ein Aufwand betrieben hat